So last time I gave a reading of the creation accounts that are in genesis one
to three.
These are two very different stories,
but their placement side by side suggests the possibility of a joint reading.
Uh,
nevertheless,
they are very different in character.
And today I want to focus in on the second creation story.
This is the story that is predominantly in genesis two and trickles into genesis
three.
And I'm going to look at it mostly in isolation from the first account.
I'm going to be looking at it in light of an important parallel.
This parallel is the epic of Gilgamesh.
I get to point this way now to the boards.
Okay,
the epic of Gilgamesh,
and I'll be drawing on the work of many scholars,
knock them Sarna probably most prominently among them,
but others also who have devoted themselves to the study of these textual
parallels and developing an interpretation of these stories and like you to
carry that with you into your discussion sections.
As you look at some of the other interpretations from antiquity and on into the
modern period.
Now,
the epic of Gilgamesh is a magnificent Mesopotamian epic that relates the
exploits of a Sumerian king,
King Gilgamesh of Orac.
That's the name of the city,
state over which he is king.
And the epic,
as we now have,
it was probably composed between 2000 and 1800 BCE.
Um,
Gilgamesh was apparently a historical character.
I get an actual king of Orac,
but the story of course,
has fantastic and legendary qualities to it.
Um,
we have a full text of the epic that was located in the library of Ashurbanipal.
a an Assyrian king.
It's a seventh century copy of the story,
but we have fragments that are much,
much older that date back to the 18th century that were found in Iraq.
So clearly it's an old story.
And we have even older prototypes for elements of the story as well.
The story opens with a description of Gilgamesh.
She's an extremely unpopular king.
He's tyrannical,
he's repaste,
he's undisciplined,
he's oversexed.
The people in the city cry out to the gods.
They want relief from him.
They particularly site his abusive towards the young women of the city.
And the God [inaudible] is told that she must deal with Gilgamesh.
A room,
um,
is on the board.
So I roof fashions.
This noble savage named Inky do
thank you.
Do is designed to be a match for Gilgamesh and he's very much like the biblical
human.
In genesis two,
he sort of an innocent,
um,
primitive.
He appears unclothed.
He lives a free,
peaceful life in harmony with the animals,
with nature and the BC races across the steps with the gazelles.
But before he can enter the city and meet Gilgamesh,
he has to be tamed.
So a woman is sent to [inaudible] and her job is to provide the sexual
initiation that will team and civilize and can you do,
I'm reading now from the epic of Gilgamesh for six days and seven nights.
And you do comes forth meeting with the less after he had had his fill of her
charms,
he set his face toward his wild beasts on seeing him.
And you do.
The gazelles ran off the wild beasts of the step drew away from his body.
Startled was thank you.
Do.
As his body became taught,
his knees were motionless for the wild beasts had gone,
and you do had to slack in his pace.
It was not as before,
but he now had wisdom,
broader understanding,
returning.
He sits at the feet of the Harlot.
Not sure why that translation,
I've been told by those who know Acadian,
that the word could mean harlot,
prostitute.
It could mean some sacred prostitute.
I'm not an expert in Akkadian,
but he looks up at the face of the Harlot.
His ears attentive as the harlot speaks,
and the hardest says to him to ask you,
do thou art wise?
Thank you.
Do you aren't become like a God?
Why?
With the wild creatures dust,
they'll Rome over the step calm.
Let me lead the Taran part.
It [inaudible] to the Holy Temple,
a boat of Uno and each car where lives Gilgamesh,
accomplished in strength and like a wild ox.
Lords it over the folk as she speaks to him.
Her words find favor.
His heart enlightened.
He yearns for a friend and he said,
thank you.
Do says to her,
to the harlot up last escort me to Gilgamesh.
I will challenge him and will boldly address him.
So that's tablet one from the epic of Gilgamesh.
So through this sexual experience and if you do has become wise growing and
mental and spiritual stature,
and he has said to have become like a god.
At the same time there's been a concomitant loss of innocence.
His harmonious unity with nature is broken.
He closed himself and his old friends,
the gazelles run from him.
Now he will never again roam free with the animals.
He cannot run as quickly his pace slackens he can't even keep up with them.
So as one reads,
the epic one senses this very deep ambivalence regarding the relative virtues
and evils,
civilized life and many of the features that make us human.
On the one hand,
it's clearly good that humans rise above the animals and build cities and wear
clothes and pursue the arts of civilization and develop bonds of love and duty
and friendship the way that animals do not.
These are the things that make humans like the gods in the epic of Gilgamesh.
But on the other hand,
these advances have also come at a cost.
And in this story,
there's also a sense of longing for the freedom of life in the wild.
The innocent,
simple,
uncomplicated life lived day to day without plans,
without toil in harmony with nature,
somewhat Edenic existence.
So there are very obvious parallels between this part of the epic that I've just
read to you and our second creation story.
And can you do like Adam is fashioned from clay.
He's a noble savage.
He's a kind of innocent,
primitive and he lives in a peaceful coexistence with animals.
Nature yields it's fruits to him without hard labor.
He's unaware of he's unattracted by the benefits of civilization,
clothing,
cities and all their labor.
Just as ANC you do gains wisdom and becomes like a God and loses his oneness
with nature.
So Adam and eve,
after eating the fruit of the knowledge of good and evil are said to have become
like gods and they also lose their harmonious relationship with nature.
Um,
in genesis three 15 God says to the snake,
I will put enmity between you and the woman and between your offspring and hers,
they shall strike it.
Your head and you shall strike at their heels.
Presumably there had been a peaceful relationship between creatures like snakes
and humans.
To that point,
they're banished now from the garden.
It used to yield their fruits to them without any labor,
but now humans have to toil for food and the the earth yields its fruit only.
Stinting Lee.
So in genesis three 18 God says to Adam,
Kersty would be the ground because of you.
By toil shall you eat of it all the days of your life.
Thorns and thistles shall it sprout for you,
but your food shall be the grasses of the field by the sweat of your brow shall
you give bread to eat.
So knowledge or wisdom or perhaps moral freedom seem to come at a very high
price.
But there are important differences between these stories too.
And the most important has to do with the nature of the act that leads to the
transformation of the human characters.
It's Encke dues,
sexual experience,
his seven day encounter with the woman that makes him wise and God like at the
cost of his life with the beasts.
There has been a long tradition of interpreting the,
um,
deed or the sin of Adam and eve and eve as sexual.
And there are some hints in the story that would support such an interpretation.
And I was just reading recently a,
um,
a scholarly,
introduction to genesis that very much argues and develops this interpretation.
Um,
Adam and eve eat from the tree of the knowledge of good and evil in violation of
God's command.
Eating can perhaps be a metaphor for sex.
Some have argued knowledge of good and evil,
perhaps that could be understood in sexual terms.
In biblical Hebrew,
the word to know can mean to know in the biblical sense.
Um,
it can mean sexual intercourse.
Uh,
snakes are symbols of renewed life and fertility in the east because they shed
their skins,
so they seem to be eternally young.
Um,
and they're also phallic symbols.
Eve says the snake seduced her and uses a term that has some sexual overtones.
So do all of these hints suggest that in the biblical view,
the change in Adam and Eve came about through sex?
If so,
is sex a negative thing for bitten by God?
It depends.
If you view the changes a negative thing that seems in my view,
you will certainly hear it argued,
but it seems unlikely in my view.
God's first command to the first couple was to be fruitful and multiply.
Now admittedly that comes from the first creation story in genesis one.
Nevertheless,
in the second creation story,
when the writer is recounting the creation of woman,
the writer refers to the fact that men and women women will become one flesh.
So it seems that sex was part of the plan for humans even at creation.
Also,
it's only after their defiance of God's command that Adam and eve first become
aware of and ashamed by their nakedness,
putting the sort of sexual awakening after the act of disobedience rather than
at the same time or or prior to.
So maybe what we have here is another polemic,
another adaptation of familiar stories and motifs to express something new
perhaps for the biblical writer,
Adam and Eve's transformation occurs after an act of disobedience,
not after a seven days sexual encounter.
The disobedience happens in a rather backhanded way.
It's kind of interesting.
God tells Adam before the creation of eve that he's not to eat of the tree of
the knowledge of good and evil.
That's in genesis two 16 on pain of death.
Eve doesn't hear this command directly.
She has not yet been created.
In genesis three,
we meet the cunning serpent and although many later a Hellenistic Jewish texts
and the New Testament,
we'll identify the snake as as a Sutton,
an enticer attempt or some sort of evil creature.
He doesn't seem to be.
So in this fable,
there's no real devil or Satan character.
We'll talk about job later.
Uh,
in the Hebrew Bible,
the snake and Eden is simply a talking animal.
He's a standard literary device that you see in fables of this period and later
the kind that you find,
for example,
in the,
um,
fables of aesop and the woman responds to the serpents queries by saying that
eating and even touching the tree is forbidden on pain of death.
One wonders.
When's the addition of touching?
Did Adam conveyed God's command to Eve with an emphasis all his own?
Don't even touch that tree.
Eve.
It's curtains for us.
If you do,
she didn't hear the original command or did she just miss here in some very
tragic version of the telephone game?
You know?
Um,
and the serpent tells her,
no,
you're not going to die if you touch your eat the fruit.
In fact,
he adds the fruit,
will bring you wisdom.
Making humans like gods who know good and bad.
And in fact,
that's certainly true.
He tells her the truth.
Genesis three seven is a very critical verse and it's rarely properly
translated.
Most translations read like this.
She took of its fruit and ate.
She also gave some to her husband and he ate.
The implication is that eve acts alone,
and then she goes and finds Adam and gives him some of the apple and convinces
him to eat it.
But in fact,
the Hebrew literally reads,
she took of its fruit and ate and gave also to her husband with her.
And he ate with her is a very teeny,
tiny little word in Hebrew.
So I guess a lot of translations figure they can leave it out,
but the width or is there in the Hebrew at that fateful moment,
Adam and eve are standing together at the tree.
And although only the woman and the serpent speak,
Adam was present and it seems he accepted the fruit that his wife handed him.
He was fully complicitness and indeed God holds him responsible.
He reproaches Adam.
Adam says,
well,
you've handed it to me.
She gave it to me.
Eve explains the serpent trick to me.
God vents his fury on all three and he does so in ascending order.
First the snake for his trickery and then the woman,
and finally the man.
So just as the Harlot tells,
Nq do after his sexual awakening that he,
um,
has become like a god.
So Adam and eve after eating the forbidden fruit are said to be like divine
beings.
Why?
Perhaps because they become,
they have become wise in that they have learned,
they have moral choice,
they have free wheel will,
they can defy God and God's plans for them in a way that animals and natural
phenomena cannot.
But now that means there is a serious danger here.
And in Genesis three verse 22 God says,
now that man has become like one of us,
knowing good and evil.
What if he should stretch out his hand and take also from the tree of life and
eat and live forever.
So it's the threat of an immortal antagonist that is so disturbing and must be
avoided.
And so God banishes,
Adam and Eve from the garden and he stations these craving these cero beam,
not puffy,
cute little babies like Raphael painted,
but these fierce,
monstrous creatures.
And if fiery ever turning sword to guard the way back to the tree of life,
it is now and accessible.
So the acceptance of mortality as an inescapable part of the human condition.
It's a part of this story.
It's also one of the themes of the epic of Gilgamesh.
As the story continues and you do enters the city and um,
and you do earns Gilgamesh is respect and deep love.
And this is the first time that this rapacious tyrant has ever actually loved
anyone in his character is reformed as a result.
And then the rest of the epic contains the adventures of these two close
friends.
All of the things that they do together.
And when Hanky do dyes,
Gilgamesh is absolutely devastated.
He's for the first time confronted with his own mortality.
He is obsessed with grief over inky do.
And he's obsessed with the whole issue of mortality.
He begins a quest for immortality,
and that takes up most of the rest of the epic.
He leaves the city,
he travels far and wide.
He crosses these primeval sees and,
and jurors,
all sorts of hardships.
And finally exhausted and,
and,
and battered.
He reaches a Pysch team also there on the board would not pitch team who is the
only mortal ever to have been granted in mortality by the gods.
Uh,
and he had becomes to him and asks for his secret.
It turns out that peach team can't help him.
Um,
and we'll come back that would not pitch team later in the flood story.
And Gilgamesh is devastated.
He then learns the whereabouts of a plant of eternal youth and he says,
well,
that's better than nothing that at least we'll keep him young.
Um,
and so he goes after the plant of eternal youth,
but he's negligent for a moment.
And a thieving snake or serpent manages to steal it.
And that explains why snakes are always shedding their skins and our forever
young Gilgamesh is exhausted.
He feels defeated.
He returns to Iraq and as he stands looking at the city from a distance,
I'm gazing at it.
He takes comfort in the thought that although humans are finite and frail and
doomed to die,
their accomplishments and their great works give them some foothold in,
in human memory.
Now not come.
Sarna is one of the people who's pointed out that the quest for immortality,
which is so central in the epic of Gilgamesh,
is really reflected in the biblical story.
The tree of life is mentioned and it's mentioned with the definite article.
Genesis two nine says with the tree of life in the middle of the garden,
as if this is a motif we're familiar with as if this is something we all know
about,
but then it's really not mentioned again,
as the story proceeds,
the snake,
which in the epic of Gilgamesh is associated with the plant of eternal youth in
genesis is associated instead with the tree of the knowledge of good and evil.
That's the focus of our attention and genesis and it's only at the end of the
story that the tree of life appears again in the passage that is emphasizing
it's permanent in accessibility.
And we could perhaps draw two conclusions from this.
First,
it may be that Adam and eve had access to this tree up to that point,
as long as there will conform to the will of God,
there was no danger to them going on eternally being immortal.
Once they discovered their moral freedom,
once they discovered that they could thwart God and work evil in the world,
um,
and abused and corrupt all that God had created,
then God cannot afford to allow them access to the tree of life that would be
tantamount to creating divine enemies and mortal enemies.
So God must maintain the upper hand in his struggle with these humans who have
learned to defy him.
He maintains the upper hand in this,
the fact that they eventually must die.
Second of all,
the Motif of guards who block access to the tree of life suggests that no humans
have access to in mortality.
And the pursuit of immortality is futile.
So it might be then that God really spoke the truth after all the fruit and did
bring death to humankind.
Before we leave this story and move on to Cain and Abel,
I just want to make a couple of quick observations.
Um,
first of all,
the opening chapters of genesis,
genesis one through three have been subjected to centuries of theological
interpretation.
And I hope that you're in the midst of reading some of them now.
Um,
they have generated,
for example,
the doctrine of original sin,
which is the idea that humans after Adam are born into a state of sin.
By definition,
as many ancient interpreters already have observed the actions of Adam and eve
bring death to the human race.
They don't bring a state of utter and unredeemed sinfulness.
In fact,
what they tell us is that humans have moral choice in each and every age.
The story is primarily ideological,
ideological rather than prescriptive or normative.
We've talked about this where ed illogical tails,
tails that are trying to explain how or why something is the way it is.
This is why serpents shed their skin.
For example,
in the epic of Gilgamesh,
they were the ones who got the plant of eternal youth.
It's Ed illogical.
The writer observes that humans emerge from innocent childhood to self conscious
adult hood.
The writer observes that survival is a difficult endeavor and that the world can
sometimes seem harshly hostile.
The writer observes that women are desirous of and emotionally bonded to the
very person who established the conditions of their subordination.
The story is explaining how these odd conditions of life came to be as they are,
which is not to say that it's the ideal situation or even that it's God's will
for humankind.
These are ecological fables and their best read.
As such.
Second of all in this story,
we see something that we'll see repeatedly in the pentitude and that is that God
has to punt a bit.
He has to modify his plans for the first couple by barring access to the tree of
life.
That was not something presumably he planned to do.
This is in response to perhaps there unforeseen disobedience.
Certainly the way the story unfolds,
it's how it seems to us,
so despite their newfound mortality,
a humans are going to be a force to be reckoned with.
They're unpredictable to the very god who created them.
Finally,
I'll just draw your attention to some interesting details that you can think
about and maybe talk about in section God ruminates that the humans have become
like one of us in the plural that echoes his words in Genesis one where he
proposes let us make humans or humankind in our image.
Again in the plural,
who was he talking to and what precisely are these chair we'll beam that are
stationed in front of the tree of life barring access.
Why do we make of these illusions to divine colleagues or subordinates and light
of Calvin's claims regarding biblical monotheism?
You should be bringing some of the things we talked about in discussing his work
into dialogue with and in conflict with some of the evidence you'll be finding
in the text itself.
So think about these things.
Don't pass over these details lightly and don't take them for granted.
The Cain and Abel story,
which is in Genesis four verses one through 16 this is a story of the first
murder and it's a murder that happens despite God's warning to Cain that it's
possible to master the urge to violence by an act of will.
He says,
sin couches at the door.
It's urges towards you,
yet you can be its master.
Genesis four verse seven now come Sarna and others have noted that the word
brother occurs throughout this story repeatedly and at climax isn't God's
question.
Where is your brother?
Abel and Cain responds,
I don't know,
am I my brother's keeper?
And ironically you sense when you read this that even though Kane and tens,
it says a rhetorical question,
am I my brother's keeper?
In fact,
he's right on the money.
Um,
yes,
we are all of us our brother's keepers.
And the strong implication of the story is a CRNA puts it that all homicide is
in fact fratricide seems to be the message of this story.
Note also,
that cane is culpable and for someone to be culpable of something,
we have to assume some principle that they have violated.
And therefore this story assumes the existence of what some writers,
Sarna among them have called the universal moral law.
There seems to be in existence from the beginning of creation,
this universal moral law and that is the God in doubt,
sanctity of human life.
If we can connect it with the fact that God has created humans in his own image,
um,
but the god endowed sanctity of human life is an assumption and it's the
violation of that assumption which makes cane culpable.
The story of Cain and Abel is notable for another theme.
And this is a theme that's going to recur in the Bible.
And that's the tension between,
um,
settled areas and the unsettled desert areas and desert life of the nomads.
Abel is a keeper of sheep.
He represents the nomadic pastoralists,
unlike Kane who is the tiller of soil.
So he represents more settled urban life.
God prefers the offering of Abel.
And as a result,
Cain is distressed and jealous to the point of murder.
God's preference for the offering of able valorizes the free life of the nomadic
pastoralists over urban existence.
And even after the Israelites will settle in their own land.
I'm the life of the desert.
Pastoralists remained a sort of romantic ideal for them.
And it's a theme that we'll see coming up in many of the stories.
It's a romantic ideal for this writer too.
Now,
the murderer of Abel by Cain is followed by some genealogical lists.
They provide some continuity between the tails.
They tell us,
um,
sort of folkloric traditions about the origins of various arts,
the origins of building,
of metalwork and music.
But finally in Genesis six,
verse five,
we read that every imagination of the thoughts of the heart,
the human heart was evil continuously.
And this sets the stage then for the story of a worldwide flood.
Now here again,
the Bible is making use of older traditions and motifs and adapting them to
their own purposes of hinted at this already.
And we'll look at it in a bit more detailed.
Now we know of a very ancient Sumerian flood story.
The hero of that one is zero dra also on the board.
Um,
we also know of a very early Semitic work,
the epic of Etra Hassis in which there's a flood with the most detailed flood
story.
We have actually comes from the epic of Gilgamesh on the 11th tablet of the epic
of Gilgamesh.
Um,
you'll remember that in his search for him,
mortality,
Gilgamesh sought out pitch team,
the one human who had been granted and mortality.
He wants to learn his secret.
And when he begs for the secret of eternal life,
he gets eaten up each team's story.
And it's the flood story.
He learns that [inaudible] him and his wife gain the immortality by a twist of
circumstances.
They were the sole survivors of this great flood and as a kind of reward,
they were given mortality.
The Sumerian story of zeal,
so is very similar to the genesis account in both.
You have the flood coming about as the deliberate result of a divine decision.
You have one individual who's chosen to be saved from the flood.
That individual has given specific instructions on building an Ark and has given
specific instructions on who to bring on board the Ark.
Um,
he's also,
um,
the arc also comes to rest on a mountaintop.
The hero sends out a bird to reconnoiter the land to find out if it's dry.
Yet when they hero emerges,
he builds an altar,
he offers sacrifice to the deity and receives a blessing.
Very similar parallel stories.
And yet there are significant contrasts between the Mesopotamian story and it's
his relight adaptation.
Let's compare some of the elements from all three of the stories with the
biblical story.
Uh,
in the epic of Gilgamesh,
we have no motive given for the divine destruction whatsoever.
It just seems to be pure capriciousness and the epic of at Hassis,
we do in fact read of a reason and the texts their states,
the land became wide and the people became numerous.
The land bellowed like wild oxen,
but God was disturbed by their uproar and little heard the clamor and said to
the gods,
oppressive has become the clamor of humankind by their upward.
They prevent sleep.
So it seems that humankind is to be destroyed because they irritate the gods
with their tumult and noise.
In the Gilgamesh,
epic Ia an Earth Water God does ask another God and Lil how he could have
brought the flood on.
Um,
so senselessly he says,
lay upon the sinner.
This sin lay upon the transgressor his transgression,
which would indicate that in the epic of Gilgamesh,
there is this element of capriciousness the biblical writer in retelling the
story seems to want to reject this idea,
um,
by providing a moral rationale for God's actions.
The earth,
the text says,
is destroyed because of Hamas.
Hamas is a word that literally means balance,
bloodshed,
but also all kinds of injustice and oppression.
Noah is saved specifically for his righteousness.
He was righteous in his generation.
He was chosen,
therefore for moral reasons.
So the writer's seems very determined to tell the story in a way that depicts
God is acting,
not capriciously,
but according to certain clear standards of justice,
this was deserved punishment and the person who was saved was righteous.
Furthermore,
in the Mesopotamian accounts,
the gods do not appear to be in control.
This is something that's been pointed out by many writers and Lil,
uh,
wants to destroy humankind completely.
He's forwarded by ear who drops hints of the disaster to Udon a peach team.
So he wound up,
each team knows what to do and therefore manages to escape the flood.
But that's thwarting the design of the God who brought the flood.
He wanted everything destroyed.
When the flood comes,
the gods themselves seem to have lost control.
Um,
they're,
they're terrified.
They cower.
The text says they cower like dogs,
crouched against the outer wall.
Ishtar the goddess Ishtar cried out like a woman in labor.
And Moreover,
during the period of the flood,
they don't have food.
They don't have sustenance.
And at the end when [inaudible] offers his sacrifice,
the gods are famished and they crowd around like the around the sacrifice like
flies.
The tech says the biblical writer wants to tell a different story.
In the biblical flood story,
God is represented as being unthreatened by the forces of nature that he
unleashes and being completely in control.
He makes the decision to punish humans because the world has corrupted itself
through Hamas to bloodshed and violence.
He selects Noah due to his righteousness and he issues a direct command to build
an Ark.
He has a clear purpose and he retains control throughout the story.
At the end,
the writer doesn't depict him as needing the sacrifice for food or sustenance.
We might say that this story like the story of Cain and Abel before it and like
the story we will read later of Sodom and Gomorrah.
This story presupposes this universal moral law that Sarna and Kaufman and
others have talked about,
right?
This universal moral law that seems to govern the world and if God sees in
fractions of it,
then as supreme judge,
he brings humans to account.
If morality is the will of God,
morality then becomes an absolute value and these infractions will be punished
in the biblical writers view.
The message of the flood story also seems to be that when humans destroyed the
moral basis of society,
when they are violent or cruel or unkind,
they endanger the very existence of that society.
The world dissolves.
So corruption and injustice and lawlessness and violence inevitably bring about
destruction.
Some writers have pointed out that it's interesting that these humans are not
being punished for for religious sense,
right dollar tree for worshiping the wrong God or anything of that nature.
And this is important.
The view of the first books of the Bible is that each nation worships,
sits own gods,
its own way perhaps at this point in the story.
Um,
perhaps the view is that all know of God even if they ignore him,
but the view eventually will be that only Israel is obligated to the god of
Israel.
Other nations aren't held accountable to for their idolatry in the books of the
Torah will see this as we as we continue along.
And yet everyone,
all humans,
Israelites and non Israelites alike by virtue of having been created by God in
the image of God,
um,
even though they may not know that God or may ignore that God,
they are bound to a basic moral law that precludes murder.
And perhaps from this story we could argue other forms of oppression and
violence.
What better way to drive home the point that in humanity and violence undermine
the very foundations of society then to describe a situation in which a cosmic
catastrophe results from human corruption and violence.
It's an idea that runs throughout the Bible.
It also appears and later Jewish thought and some Christian thought,
some Islamic thought,
the psalmist is going to use this motif.
Um,
when he denounces um,
social injustice,
the exploitation of the poor and so on.
He says,
through wicked deeds like this,
all the foundations of the earth are moved,
are shaken.
The Noah story,
the flood story ends with the ushering in of a new era.
And it is in many ways a second creation that mirrors the first creation in some
important ways.
But this time God realizes,
and again,
this is where God's got to punt all the time.
It's what I love about the first part of Genesis.
God is trying to figure out what he has made and what he's done.
And he's got to shift modes all the time.
And God realizes that he's going to have to make a concession.
He's going to have to make a concession to human weakness and the human desire
to kill and is going to have to rectify the circumstances that made his
destruction of the earth necessary in the first place.
So he establishes a covenant with Noah Covenant and humankind receives its first
set of explicit laws.
No more implicit.
You know,
murder is bad.
Oh,
I wish I had known.
Right now we're getting our first explicit set of laws and they're universal in
scope on the biblical writers view.
They applied to all humanity,
not just Israel.
So these are often referred to as the terms of the Noaa hide covenant.
They apply to all humanity.
This covenant explicitly prohibits murder in Genesis nine that is the spilling
of human blood.
Blood is the symbol of life.
That's a connection that's made elsewhere in the Bible.
Leviticus 17 right?
The life is in the blood,
so blood is the biblical symbol for life,
but God is going to make a concession to the human appetite for power and
violence.
Previously,
humans were to be vegetarian.
Genesis one the portrait was one in which humans and animals did not compete for
food or consume one another.
Humans were vegetarian.
Now God is saying humans may kill animals to eat them,
but even so,
he says,
the animal's life is to be treated with reverence and the blood,
which is the life essence must be poured out on the ground,
return to God,
not consumed,
so the animal may be eaten to satisfy the human hunger for flesh,
but the life essence itself belongs to God.
It must not be taken even if it's for the purposes of nourishment.
Genesis nine verses four through six you shall not eat flesh with its life.
That is its blood for your lifeblood.
I will surely require a reckoning of every beast.
I will require it and of humans.
So if you are killed by a BS story,
human,
there will have to be a reckoning and accounting of every person's brother.
I will require the life of the person,
whoever shoved sheds the blood of a person in exchange for that person shall his
blood be shed for God made humans in his image all life,
human and animal is sacred to God.
The covenant also entails God's promise to restore the rhythm of life and nature
and never again to destroy the earth.
The rainbow is set up as a symbol of the eternal covenant,
a token of the eternal reconciliation between the divine and human realms.
And we should note that this notion or this idea of a god who can even make and
keep an eternal covenant is only possible on the view that God's word and we'll
our absolute in susceptible to nullification by some superior power or some
divine antagonist.
Now,
um,
you worked,
I,
I handed out or there was handed out to you a sheet of paper.
You might want to get that out in front of you because we're going to talk a
little bit about the flood story in genesis six through nine.
Um,
when we read the flood story in Genesis six through nine were often struck by
the very odd literary style.
I hope you were struck by the odds that are very style and the repetitiveness
and the contradictions.
So I want to ask you now and,
and,
and be brave and speak out,
um,
in your reading of the story,
did anything of that nature strike you?
Was a story hard to follow?
Was it self contradictory and in what ways?
Anything?
Just don't even be polite.
Just throw it right out there.
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
We seem to have two sets of instructions,
right?
Someone's pointing out here.
We seem to have two sets of instructions about what to bring on board.
I had to bring two of each sort of living thing,
animals and birds and creeping things.
Or in another passage,
God tells Moses to bring on seven pairs of pure animals.
Um,
and one pair of impure animals and seven pairs of birds,
right?
Different sets of instructions.
Anything else strike you as odd when you were reading this story?
Okay.
Rain seems to be there for different amounts of time,
doesn't it?
There are some passages in which the flood is said to last for 40 days or beyond
the earth for 40 days.
You find that in genesis seven,
verse 17,
but in Genesis seven verse 24,
150 days is given us the time of the flood.
Anything else?
Any other sorts of doublets or contradictions?
Okay,
because there are a few more.
Who's giving the instructions?
That's not hard.
You haven't right in front of you who's giving the instructions.
Okay.
God,
we have the word God being used,
I guess in that translation,
right?
With a capital g,
what else is used?
Lord?
Those are actually different Hebrew words underneath there.
Okay.
Those two terms are different names for the dd that's giving the instruction.
Okay,
so there are two designation is used for God,
Yahweh way,
which is the sacred Tetra Gramaton.
It's written with four letters in Hebrew.
There you don't include avowals.
Um,
we don't really know how it's pronounced.
I'm guessing it your way and that is a proper name for God and in your
translation that will be translated as lord in small caps.
So wherever you see lord in small caps,
that's actually the English translation for yeah way.
Um,
the proper name,
like a,
almost a personal name for God.
And then in other places we have this word Elohim,
which um,
actually is the word for God's a sort of generic term for deities in the plural.
However,
when it's used to refer to the god of Israel,
it's clearly singular.
It always has a singular verb.
So that will be appearing in your text as God with a capital g.
Okay.
So whenever you see Lord or God,
those are actually pointing to different words that are being used in the
underlying Hebrew text.
Twice God has said to look down on creation twice.
It has said that he is displeased twice.
He decides to destroy all living things twice the issues,
instructions.
And as we've seen,
they're contradictory.
We seem to also have a different account of how long the flood lasted.
There are more subtle contradictions throughout as well.
Sometimes the flood seems to the be the result of very heavy rain,
but in other descriptions it seems to be a real cosmic of upheaval.
You'll remember the description of the world from genesis one as an air bubble
essentially that's formed by separating waters above and waters below and
they're held back.
We're pressed back by the firmament above and it's the windows in the firmament
that are open.
Those waters are allowed to rush in and dissolve that air bubble.
It's as if we're back to square one with the deep right.
Just this watery mass again.
So it's creation undoing itself in some of the descriptions as opposed to just
heavy rain.
And in keeping with that idea of a kind of a return to chaos,
Noah is represented in a way as the beginning of a new creation because like
Adam and eve and the first creation story,
no as told to be fruitful and multiply.
He's also given rule over everything and that's now extended to the taking of
human life.
The Bible contains a lot of repetition in contradiction and sometimes it occurs
in one passage as in the flood story here and sometimes it occurs in stories are
passages that are separate from one another.
For example,
the two creation stories,
there are many significant differences between the two creation stories.
They differ greatly in style.
Genesis one is formalized.
It's highly structured,
right?
It has the seven days and everything is paired up and it's beautifully
structured.
It's very abstract.
Genesis two,
as much more dramatic,
much more earthy.
Um,
the first creation story doesn't really contain puns and word plays.
It's a little bit serious.
The second creation story is full of them are all sorts of little ironies and
puns in the,
in the Hebrew,
a dumb the earthling made from the earth.
A dom is made from Adam Ma.
Adam and Eve are naked.
A room,
which is the same word for clever or shrewd and the snake is our room.
He's clever and shrewd.
They,
there are lots of little puns of this kind.
There are also differences in terminology between the two stories.
Genesis one speaks of male and female.
It's that one set of Hebrew terms,
but genesis two uses man and woman,
a different set of Hebrew terms to describe the genders.
So the gender,
the terms for gender are different in the two stories.
Genesis one refers to God as in your translation,
God,
Elohim,
the word that's a translated as God.
He's remote,
he's transcendent,
he creates effortlessly through his word and through his will.
But Genesis two we first the deity as a name.
That's really a combination.
It's Yahweh Elohim.
So you'll see Lord God,
right?
You see that a lot in the Bible as well.
Lord God,
that tells you that both of those words are side by side in the original Hebrew.
So in genesis two the DD is Yahweh Elohim.
He's much more down to earth.
He forms the human like a potter,
working with clay.
He talks to himself.
He plants a garden,
he takes a stroll in the garden in the cool of the evening.
He makes clothes for Adam and eve.
He's spoken of and much more anthropomorphic terms.
Then the God that we encounter in genesis one.
So what we have in the first few chapters of genesis are two creation stories.
They have distinctive styles,
distinctive themes,
distinctive vocabularies and their place side by side.
In genesis six through nine we seem to have two flood stories with distinctive
styles and themes and vocabularies and substantive details,
but they're interwoven instead of being placed side by side and there are many
such doublets in the Bible at times we have whole books that repeat or go over
the same material.
In fact,
the whole historical saga that's recorded from genesis through the end of second
kings is rehearsed again in the books of first and second chronicles.
What are we to make of the repetitions and the contradictions here and
throughout the Bible?
What are the implications?
Suppose you came across a piece of writing that you knew nothing about,
just lying there on the table.
You didn't know who wrote it,
where,
when,
how,
why,
and someone says,
I want you to draw some conclusions about that piece of writing.
I want you to draw some conclusions about it's authorship and the way it was
compiled or composed and so you pick it up and you start reading and you notice
features like this.
What my,
to conclude,
throw it out.
What might you conclude?
No presuppositions.
You pick up the work and you find these features.
What might you conclude about its author,
shipper manner of composition?
Yeah.
You might conclude that there are multiple authors write multiple authorship.
That revisions may have been made so that you might have different sources that
have been revised or put together in different ways,
right?
Visions implying you've got something and then it's worked over again.
Additions might be made,
so now that's a new source.
Right?
You might conclude that these features are evidence of multiple authorship,
a good deal of revision,
which points itself to a kind of composite structure,
different layers,
maybe different sources.
Well,
as early as the Middle Ages,
there were some scholars who noticed these things in the biblical texts,
they noticed that there were contradictions and repetitions and there are
anachronisms.
Two other features that were evidence of multiple authorship revisions and
composite structure.
So what,
why would that be a big deal?
Okay.
We can all go home then there's no problem with that.
Right?
Why would that be a big deal?
Yeah.
Okay.
It could be a bit of a problem if this text has become the basis for a system of
religious faith or belief and your assumptions about it are that it's telling a
truth that is singular in nature.
And also what about the traditional beliefs in the origin of this text?
Right?
Who wrote this text going into traditional beliefs?
I'm hearing Moses,
I'm hearing God.
I'm hearing a bunch of different things,
but right.
There are traditional ideas about generally the mosaic authorship of the Bible,
certainly the first five books of the Bible.
And so these features of the text,
which were noticed were a challenge to traditional religious convictions
regarding the mosaic authorship of the first five books of the Bible.
And in many ways,
the perfection of the Bible as speaking with a unified voice on matters of
doctrine or religious theology.
So medieval commentators,
for example,
um,
began to speak a little bit more openly about some of these features.
One of the first things they noticed is that Deuteronomy 34 describes the death
and burial of Moses.
So they decided it was possible that Moses didn't write at least that chapter.
Similarly,
there were some anachronisms that they had to explain.
One of the most famous is in genesis 13 verse seven.
It's a midst of a story about dividing the land between lot and at that time,
his name is Abraham.
Later becomes Abraham.
But between lot and Abraham and the narrator in telling the story sort of
interjects and turns to us,
the readers and says the Canaanites and parasites were then dwelling in the
land.
Now,
what's weird about that sentence?
The narrator is speaking to us from a time in which the Canaanites and parasites
don't live in the land,
right?
That's back when the native Americans lived in Connecticut.
Is that right?
Are Living at a time when native Americans are still living in Connecticut or
owning Connecticut?
No.
They're writing from a later point of view.
So the narrator breaks and talks to the audience in genesis 13 and seven says
that was back in the time and the Canaanites were in the land.
When did Moses live?
Who lived in the land and the time of Moses?
The Canaanites,
I know you haven't gotten there yet,
but when you get to Deuteronomy,
you're going to find out he doesn't make it into the land.
So he never makes it in there.
He's never gets in before the Israelites conquer.
He dies.
The Canaanites are still in possession.
So that line was certainly written not by Moses,
is written by someone at a much later time who's looking back and referring to
the time when the Canaanites were in the land.
So these are the kinds of things that people began to notice.
And with the rise of rationalism in the modern period,
traditional notions of the divine and mosaic authorship of the Pentateuch or the
Torah.
The first five books of Moses were called into question.
The modern critical study of the Bible begins really with Spinosa who in the
early 17th century suggested that the Bible should be studied and examined.
Like any book without presuppositions,
without presuppositions about its divine origin,
or any other dogmatic claims about its composition or authorship.
But it was a Catholic priest,
Richard Cmon.
We shard Simone,
who first argued that Moses didn't write the Torah and that it contained many
anachronisms and errors.
We've run out of time.
But I'll pick up this fascinating story on Wednesday and we'll learn a little
bit more about tradition,
uh,
about critical ideas about the composition of the Bible.
Please be on the lookout for emails from section leaders with study guides for
sections,
which will be meeting this week.
You'll have a lot of fun with the creation stories.